bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le dernier
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo
comme chaque vendredi nous allons faire
un tour d'horizon de l'actualité de la
semaine dans le département
au sommaire de cette édition c'est une
tradition pour le 14 juillet le feu
d'artifice plusieurs communes de saint
quentin en yvelines ont prévu des
festivités dès ce soir nous nous sommes
rendus à plaisir pour découvrir les
derniers préparatifs
reportage à suivre france croatie c'est
la fiche de la finale de la coupe du
monde de football dans les yvelines
plusieurs écrans géants sont prévus pour
suivre la rencontre performance des
bleus retombées auprès de jeunes
footballeurs yvelinois nous recevons
mustapha larbaoui président d'honneur de
l'étoile sportive de trappes
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité nous
reviendrons sur le discours d' emmanuel
macron devant le congrès à versailles
retour aussi sur les formations au
numérique proposé à saint quentin en
yvelines à partir de septembre
deuxième week-end de départ en vacances
et bison futé voit rouge dans le sens
des départs pour la journée de samedi
sur l'autoroute a10 au niveau du péage
de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines le pic de
circulation est attendu entre 9 heures
et 11 heures avec un trafic dans ceux
prévus jusqu'à 14h pour dimanche bison
futé prévoit une circulation dense entre
8h et 17h malgré une journée classée
verte dans le sens des départs
86,3 % c'est le taux de réussite au bac
dans l'académie de versailles pour
l'édition 2018 une diminution de 0,3
point par rapport à l'an dernier
les yvelines ont le meilleur taux de
réussite dans l'ensemble des
départements de l'académie
le taux dépasse les 93 % pour les
filières générales 88 % pour les
filières technologiques et les 80% pour
le baccalauréat professionnel
la région ile de france à la rencontre
des entrepreneurs c'était ce matin au
ski tube la vice présidente en charge du
développement économique
alexandra du blanche s'est rendu ce
matin pour présenter les aides
régionales pour les entrepreneurs de
cibler pour les tpe et pme une pour les
entreprises innovantes et une dernière
pour les sociétés ans
difficulté écoutez ses explications au
micro d'aurélie rose un tps et 55000
euros maximum
pm pour va jusqu'à 250 mille euros et
innov'up l'an passé un peu à l'étape du
dessus ça va alors ses cent mille euros
en terme de subventions c'est à dire un
chèque de la région et ça peut aller
jusqu'à un million d'euros en avances
récupérables c'est à dire on fait une
avance que l'entreprise nous rend après
tout ce qu'on fait en développement
économique qui a les aides aux
entreprises mais parme cet endroit où
nous sommes aujourd'hui c'est financer
massivement par la région par exemple
qui a plein d'autres choses
atos qui à proximité qu'on finance
également donc ce ne sont pas que les
aides directes aux entreprises
certains d'entre vous sont en vacances
eu d'autre travail travaillent
d'arrache-pied pour le 14 juillet ce
sont les artificiers en 2010 est près de
15000 feu ont été tirés en france au
château de plaisir on est en pleine
installation la commune s'est associée
avec sa voisine des clayes-sous-bois
pour fêter le 14 juillet un reportage de
mélanie poquet des cartons par dizaines
qu'il faut trier et vider des mortiers
accabler les onze artificiers sont sur
le pont depuis 9h30 ce vendredi matin le
point final de cinq mois de préparation
on parle le nombre de lignes de produits
donc généralement on est là on a une
centaine de lignes qui fait pourquoi
250 300 produits mais pas fait parce que
les produits qui font 25 30 ou 100 coups
ou les choses comme ça d'où il ya du
matériel
la discussion de fond avec les mérites
généralement début février et ensuite va
essayer d échange pour savoir les telles
qu'elles sont il faut donc on en est
sûrs de deux mois et demi trois mois
cette année plaisir et les
clayes-sous-bois vont célébrer la
chanson française
une création de la société au rythme de
la musique et des lasers avec au coeur
du dispositif le château de plaisir pas
plus que ça et qui m'a versé la 95e la
smith qui me fait tout de suite ça vous
serez pas emmerder on utilise des gros
calibres mais en toute sécurité avec le
château effectivement qui nous protège
le public mais bon on fait quand même
attention on profite aussi du site
on essaie d'inventer en fonction du site
que l'on a on n'a pas toujours des trucs
sympathiques mais là encore on en
profite du château on peut jouer avec
les arbres l'aller on peut jouer avec le
château la façade montage câblage test
les artificiers seront à pied d'oeuvre
toute la soirée premier feu tiré à 23
heures dimanche 15 juin les français
vont pousser derrière les bleus la
france affronte la croatie pour la
finale de la coupe du monde de football
russie 2018
c'est à 17h pour suivre ce match sur
écran géant à saint quentin en yvelines
plusieurs possibilités le vélodrome
nationale ouvre ses portes à partir de
16 heures
une retransmission sur les écrans géants
de l'enceinte sportive dans les autres
communes magny les hameaux installe un
dispositif dans la salle de l'estaminet
à plaisir ce sera au stade j en bois
d'arcy à l'abri blues ou à fontenay le
fleury au parc delà des ménages en
poudre 1 peut enfin enfin vous pourrez
aussi vivre la rencontre à versailles un
écran sur installé sur la place du
marché notre dame
vous pouvez vous y rendre à partir de
15h30 et pour parler de cette finale
nous accueillons mustapha larfaoui
bonsoir bonsoir alors mustapha quel est
votre programme vous pour dimanche soir
à priori à partir de 15h 16h jeux
devrait être pas loin du vélodrome
puisque on nous a invités et je remercie
la ville nouvelle de le faire du côté du
vélodrome pour tout vous dire pour
suivre ce match avec un maximum
d'enfants du club de foot au passage qui
ne verront pas localement puisqu'on nous
a interdit de faire quelque chose sur
trappe
j'ai vu qu'ils avaient des villes qu'ils
aient en ce qui nous concerne on nous a
interdit de le faire
on m'a interdit de le faire donc on ira
au vélodrome comme nous l'a suggéré
alors je rappelle que vous êtes
président d'honneur de l'étoile sportive
de trappes
l'équipe de france va jouer son
troisième sa troisième finale de coupe
du monde après 1998 et 2006 c'est une
équipe jeune moyenne d'âge 26 ans est la
plus jeune équipe de la compétition
quels sont les facteurs de l'arrêt de
réussite de cette sélection dès le 18
depuis le début le facteur clé de succès
de cette équipe c'est didier deschamps
et à ce titre là j'ai envie de dire il
ya eu clairement dans mon esprit le
sentiment qui a une véritable passation
entre aimé jacquet qui l'a eu dans son
équipe et j'ai l'impression que aimé
jacquet était déjà dans l'idée qu'un
jour il serait sélectionnant cette
équipe de france et qui la mènera
jusqu'au bout pour avoir senti aimé
jacquet dans ses méthodes et et d'avoir
capter l'énergie que aimé jacquet avait
transmis à l'époque des cris et déjà à
l'époque et didier deschamps ça fait un
petit peu mal commencé en pensant qui
faisait pas forcément les bons choix
mais je crois que le facteur clé de
succès ça reste quand même
un coach c'est super important pour ne
pas dire de grève c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné on va on va claquer les
présidents de ligues ou de chez des
quand ça va mal et quand ça va bien on
oublie de dire un mot pour ces gens là
donc bravo à monsieur la grève bras à
noël donc le greffe
bravo à didier deschamps et après cette
équipe quick a su mais encore une fois
bien encadré a su tirer le meilleur est
con ce qui a su surtout bien se préparer
alors là d'autres qui se préparent
mustapha larfaoui vous allez le voir à
quelques heures de cette finale les
supporters sont dale d'un dans la
dernière ligne droite pour se préparer à
cette finale si c'est compliqué de
trouver des maillots officiels de
l'équipe de france plusieurs
alternatives sont disponibles un
reportage signé michael et demi d'euros
et patrick jacques de dixmude chapeau
drapeau corne de brume ce vendredi 13
juillet carlo supporters de l'équipe de
france a décidé de s'équiper aux
couleurs des bleus pour soutenir les
tricolores contre la croatie ce dimanche
15 juillet c'est important ces firmes
ont manqué faut marquer c'est un moment
que fethi festif même sur le père c'est
important de marquer le coup là dessus
c'est le foot quand on aime le foot on a
besoin d'avoir tout ça avec nous ça n'a
pas tout ça dans une finale de foot
c'est pas en finale
carlos n'est pas le seul à vouloir
préparer ce rendez vous depuis la
qualification de la france pour la
finale sept boutiques de déguisements de
maurepas voit déferler des hordes de
supporters ils frisent la rupture de
stock sur certains produits
le best-seller le drapeau tricolore des
impôts c'est énorme on est livrés tous
les jours on essaie de se faire livrer
tous les jours on pleure avec les
fournisseurs pour être librement
on a une raison en cours encore
aujourd'hui on a à peu près 300 pièces
qui lui arrive et du drapeau du derniers
préparatifs également pour les
restaurants et les bars ici à montigny
le bretonneux à deux jours de la finale
le gérant montrent un support pour
installer un écran géant à l'extérieur
de l'établissement
objectif pouvoir accueillir plus de 300
supporters
le plus grand moment de l'histoire du
bar et le plus grand moment de
l'histoire de la coupe du monde après 98
on espère revivre ça encore une nouvelle
fois avec le plus de monde possible
voilà on attend les clients très
nombreux la joie la bonne humeur la
festivité le plus important est de toute
façon nous quoiqu'il arrive les équipes
sont prêtes prêts à vous accueillir
donc c'est que du bonheur il ne reste
plus qu'à attendre une victoire de la
france contre la croatie en finale ce
dimanche 15 juillet à 17 heures pour que
la fête soit encore plus belle
alors on l'a vu les supporters sont au
rendez-vous aujourd'hui les stars de
l'équipe de france il ya killian mba
pays à ngolo quand tu es raphaël varane
ou encore hugo lloris
cela peut créer des vocations pour les
jeunes on voit que au lieu que ce soit
les attaquants qui sont mis en avant
dans cette compétition mise à part qu'il
ya même bas p c'est plutôt les
défenseurs est ce que ça peut justement
déplacés l'évocation des jeunes qui
souhaitent marquer des buts être
attaquant est maintenant peut-être
défendre faire le meilleur tacle mettre
la pression à l'adversaire quand on
regarde nos enfants debout très très
jeunes ils ont des profils quasiment eux
mêmes c'est à dire qu'ils sont eux-mêmes
destinée gardien à être arrière milieu
de terrain ou avant centre on peut avoir
la tentation de vouloir ressembler à ses
idoles qui son avant-centre et de parler
en avoir les qualités de la même façon
on peut avoir tendance à vouloir
ressembler à un arrière et ne pas lui
ressembler et non pas en avoir les
qualités non plus donc oui ils sont
hantés par leurs idoles il ya beaucoup
de mimétisme aussi il ya beaucoup de
dents vie de leur ressembler de faire la
même chose mais il ya quand même les
qualités intrinsèques chez des enfants
qui fait qu'ils vont occuper les postes
qu'ils devront occuper au passage quand
on parle des enfants moi je n'oublie
jamais que le football ça reste quand
même un prétexte pour un loisir et pour
l'éducation par exemple il serait bien
expliqué les trois couleurs
on parle beaucoup du drapeau tricolore
nous nos enfants puisque dans le cadre
de pharma citoyens on a besoin
d'expliquer beaucoup de choses au
travers du foot les valeurs de la
république les valeurs de la laïcité les
valeurs entre guillemets de ce qu'ils
incarnent cette république par exemple
drapeaux les trois couleurs doit
viennent qu'est ce que ça veut dire le
rouge le blanc le bleu la même façon
d'où vient le football parce que nous on
est tous on a tendance à l'oublier aux
fins en faveur de ces stars et qui gomme
finalement l'idée qu'on se fait nous
dans les clubs amateurs
nous les bénévoles d'un modèle de
football éducatif où se situe l'humain
aujourd'hui dans le football on parle
beaucoup d'argent dans les clubs
amateurs
la disponibilité des joueurs on va le
voir à l'image au dernier entraînement à
clairefontaine avant le départ en russie
les joueurs qui étaient disponibles
autour des enfants à signer des
autographes à prendre des photos des
celle ci aujourd'hui quelle est cette
place de deux justement de la
disponibilité des joueurs auprès d'un
public
je pense qu'ils sont bien briefé il ya
une époque où ce n'était pas du tout le
cas
il ya eu une autre époque où c'était
tellement des stark à la limite on
pouvait comprendre qu'il soit tellement
sollicité qu'il fallait les protéger de
la même façon je crois que l'on arrive à
un mix et on les a bien briefé on voit m
bape est par exemple qui va redonner ce
qui va donner ses primes
à des associations j'en ai connu
d'autres issues de trappes à une autre
époque star avec beaucoup d'argent qui
ne reversait absolument rien même quand
ça ne lui revenait pas à lui 1
on a eu les projecteurs sur trappe dans
le cadre de l'année le cas par exemple
aujourd'hui les projos sont sur bondy je
crois que tous ces gens là sont
maintenant bien briefé il s'agit quand
même de regarder la société civile
autrement de regarder le drapeau
français autrement de chanter la
marseillaise autrement je crois qu'ils
sont quand même en terme de com bien
briefé et c'est tant mieux
justement le dernier joueur à être
sortis des rangs de trappes du club de
football de trappes c'est nicolas anelka
vous en parler on va voir des images
d'ailleurs 20 ans en arrière nicolas
anelka disponibles auprès des jeunes de
trappes
comment on accompagne les joueurs
jusqu'au professionnalisme comme avec
l'exemple de nicolas anelka
dès le plus jeune âge à la trappe dans
les clubs amateurs est ce que il existe
un mba b trappistes peut-être un futur
mba petra piste je veux rompre avec
cette idée selon lesquelles ce sont des
clubs qui font les mômes
encore une fois nous n'avons pas fait un
tel qu'un attrape et je ne peux pas
croire une seconde que bondy est fait
m pap et quand on est bon on a
l'habitude de le dire nous quand on est
bon on est bon il ya un môme il est doué
il a un talent pur
on les accompagne on ne fait parler
mbappé de demain il existe et c'est là
où un moment donné je trouve que cette
idée selon laquelle une commune peut
briller pendant l'instant pendant un
instant avec sa star du moment
je trouve ça très déplacée parce qu'à
limite ils auraient pu faire anelka
aurait très bien pu faire ses classes à
elancourt franchement ou à guyancourt où
à maurepas
il était doué il était il avait du
talent en revanche est un vrai talent
français au niveau des clubs amateurs et
c'est ça qu'il faut promouvoir
on a des stars mais parce qu'ils le sont
de façon aléatoire ils sont dans des
villes plus ou moins voilà celle de
trappes celle de bondy etc
mais ce ne sont pas des territoires ou
des terroirs propice à des graines de
stars ils le sont ils sont là moi je
préfère qu'on parle des clubs amateurs
de tous les clubs amateurs du talent
français à former tous nos éducateurs et
donc en réalité la star ça reste le
football et ça reste les méthodes
françaises
alors les lycées 39 me licencier plus de
mille licenciés au club de trappes
qu'est ce que vous attendez en termes de
retombées de cette coupe du monde
réussie on peut le dire l'objectif
c'était les demi finales pour l'équipe
de france on sait pas encore si elle va
remporter la coupe du monde mais ce il
va ya voir quelles retombées à quelles
retombées vous attendez on notera porno
n'attend pas beaucoup parce qu'on est
déjà très nombreux et on n'a pas des
capacités extensible nous on mise
beaucoup sur le foot pratiqué par les
filles
je trouve qu'on a n'a pas parlé
suffisamment même c'est l'occasion d'en
part de parler de la coupe du monde foot
hommes et y aura la coupe du monde au
féminin à l'an prochain on mise beaucoup
nous sur les filles pas tellement en
termes de nombre il a encore une fois
cette qualité du football que l'on que
l'on veut promouvoir et cette coupe du
monde est toujours un prétexte pour nous
pour en parler encore une fois pour
parler du drapeau pour parler des
valeurs du foot pour parler de ce qu'on
a envie de transmettre
il n'y a pas que des stars et des gens
qui vont devenir milliardaire du foot il
ya aussi tout simplement pour la grande
majorité voire la totalité de jeunes
citoyens en devenir et c'est ça notre
boulot et quand vous disiez comment les
accompagnent nous les
pas vraiment par contre s'il peut y
avoir de lavage isation des modèles où
on va chercher nos mômes un peu partout
parce qu'il ya du pognon à se faire dans
les intermédiaires et ça ça aussi nous
si on les récupère tous ces mondes donc
pas les stars c'est bien mais il ya il
ya un système à promouvoir c'est celui
de l'éducation à la française par le
foot comme dans l'éducation nationale
avant de clôturer cette page football
un mot sur les images qu'on a pu voir
pour la demi-finale les champs elysées
rempli de monde des images même à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines beaucoup de
monde qui ont célébré cette victoire
après la victoire de la france face à la
belgique est ce qu'il n'ya pas un vent
de 1998 qui plane
il ya un vent de 1998 si on reste sur
l'idée que la france va en finale et on
a tous cette joie cette voie là cet
emballement à vouloir suivre et à pour
suivre l'événement
là dessus on peut dire que c'est réussi
en plus le marketing fait bien son
boulot et on voit bien tous ces gens qui
nous vendent des produits à ce niveau là
oui pour le reste le modèle est
différent à l'époque on avait plaqué un
modèle qui était celui de la black blanc
beur et savait créer une voie là
d'autres d'autres d'autres réflexes on
les appuie maintenant il y en a d'autres
mais mel enthousiasme pour l'équipe de
france
d'enthousiasmé existe on aurait voulu le
transmettre et le voir sur trappe qu'on
n'est pas demain des images pour dire
que tu rappes ne s'est pas célébrer ni
le drapeau ni les couleurs de la france
ni nos joueurs ni nos bleus on les aime
on est derrière eux on veut manifester
notre joie et notre enthousiasme pour
eux on aurait voulu le faire le
démontrer peut-être que quelqu'un dira
le contraire un jour et ce n'est pas
vrai je le dis par avance alors vous
savez larbaoui rester avec nous on passe
tout de suite au résumé de l'actualité
de la semaine
c'était sa deuxième intervention devant
l'ensemble des parlementaires le
président de la république emmanuel
macron a tenu un discours d'une heure
trente ce lundi 9 juillet devant le
congrès réuni à versailles réforme
constitutionnelle réduction des dépenses
publiques plan pauvreté le chef de
l'état a tracé le cadre de son action
pour l'année à venir écouter didier
baichère député la république en marge
de la première circonscription des
yvelines c'était au micro de nicolas
kirillovitch à la base moi j'ai re deux
discours effectivement très social il
est revenu à de très nombreuses reprises
même pour l'éducation en insistant en
fait sur le volet de vouloir sortir les
jeunes de leur quartier et c'est pour ça
qu'on fait le par exemple dédoublement
des classes de cp et de ce1
on a beaucoup insisté sur la lutte
contre la pauvreté la précarité qui sera
un enjeu de l'année 2010 9,1 à la même
cité créé l'état providence du 21e
siècle
en parlant également de la dépendance
qui va être un grand sujet de l'année
parce qu'on peut pas continuer à voir
les familles face à al isolement de nos
aînés et ça fait un très très grand
chantier de l'année 2019 avec alors
mustapha larbaoui un mot sur la
politique du président de la république
concernant les banlieues il a commandé
un rapport à jean louis borloo sur le
sujet vous étiez présent d'ailleurs à
l'elysée lorsqu'il a été remis qu'est ce
que vous attendez à attrape non
seulement présents à l'elysée pour le la
remise de ce plan borloo
mais surtout on ya travaillé puisqu'on a
participé à des commissions
plusieurs commissions pour apporter des
solutions il y en a à travers le foot
y'a des propositions à faire
mais tous les sports en général en dans
les cuves et comme il les appelle
maintenant les cartes quartier politique
de la ville voilà donc clairement tout
on a bien compris le plan borloo on va
pas en parler
probablement qu'il y aura un plan macro
parce que ça continue de dire que moi je
continue à aller au ministère j'ai
encore rencontré
le ministre de la cohésion des
territoires
jacques mézard laura flessel le
président du comité national olympique
voilà on continue à travailler sur ces
options parce qu'il faut continuer pour
l'emploi dans ces quartiers et puis le
monde associatif
moi je suis convaincu qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses à faire qui ne coûte pas grand
chose
j'en suis pratiquement une preuve
incarnée en 14 ans on n'a pas dépensé
énormément au regard de ce que ça coûte
un club de foot et au regard des
résultats
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire et macron à un mot que j'aime
beaucoup
nous ne devons pas être assigné à
résidence
ça veut dire qu'à un moment donné il
faut ouvrir ces territoires et moi ça je
j'y crois beaucoup
il faut ouvrir maintenant c'est un
discours je les écoutais ce sont des
discours mais moi en tant que président
j'en ai fait aussi des discours ce qui
est important c'est l'action et dans la
durée donc j'ai entendu on va regarder
on va attendre mais il faut maintenant
des résultats parce que faut pas
attendre que ça nous pète dans la gueule
pour réagir à chaque fois de façon au
coup par coup
il faut prendre les choses vraiment en
amont mois dans le foot j'ai mis
quatorze ans à arriver à un petit petit
résultat mais modeste intéressant c'est
des politiques long terme qu'il faut
nous ça fait là bas oui merci d'être
venu sur notre plateau je rappelle qu'on
est président d'honneur de l'étoile
sportive de trappes bonne finale merci
et vive la france
merci pour mieux faire connaître ces
formations labellisées école du
numérique saint quentin en yvelines
organisée lundi après-midi attrape une
réunion développement web ou encore
réseaux et sécurité le public a pu
découvrir 13 formations disponibles à
partir du niveau bac
aurélie rond et karl a dit jean était
sur place devenir analyste en
cybersécurité ou assistons de
sécurisation de données
dès la rentrée treize formation
labellisée école du numérique seront
disponibles sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
en tout 300 futurs talents s'apprête à
être formés c'est les emplois de demain
vous savez bien
et puis les entreprises nous ont fait
part de leurs besoins et on a souhaité
venir d organiser formation qui n'était
pas à saint quentin en yvelines pour
qu'elles proposent des formations qui
correspondent aux besoins des
entreprises
cet organisme ont présenté leur
formation comme o'clock
il propose de vous apprendre les bases
du métier de développeur web tout en
restant chez vous on est à distance chez
soi la plupart du temps à domicile mais
en interaction permanente avec un
formateur qui est en direct vidéo avec
qui on échange comme comme s'il était à
côté et on l'entend il nous entend on
peut lui parler et en interaction
permanente aussi avec les autres
stagiaires
la formation commence tous les jours à 9
heures jusqu'à midi après une pause pour
déjeuner à 13 heures reprend jusqu'à 15
heures la plupart de ces formations est
accessible sans diplôme particulier et
s'adresse donc un large public
j'ai un petit job hors intérimaires et
cette année j'ai envie de me reconvertir
dans le numérique
je trouvais ce que cherche à au moins
trois formations qui m'intéresse
beaucoup
le numérique un secteur d'avenir à saint
quentin en yvelines qui a recensé en un
an dix mille offres d'emploi le
traditionnel défilé militaire du 14
juillet plus de 4000 hommes et femmes
descendront les champs elysées un
événement minime et très qui se prépare
les troupes à pied s'entraînent toute la
semaine dans les yvelines au camp
militaire de satory
aurélie rond a suivi un de ses
entraînements
armées de terre de l'air marine ou
encore gendarmerie depuis le début de la
semaine à satory tout le monde marche au
pas les répétitions pour le défilé du
14-juillet s'enchaînent sur le site
militaire yvelinois qui présentent
quasiment les mêmes caractéristiques
techniques que les champs elysées dans
les rangs cette année un régiment
habitués le spy basée à valence et qui
revient tout juste du mali y aura
toujours des petites choses qui vont pas
sur les premières répétitions au fur et
à mesure des heures à mesure des
entraînements individuellement que
collectivement on s'améliore pour
finalement donner une impression une
impression d'ensemble qui soit la plus
belle possible
silence et sérieux sont de rigueur
lorsque le général passe les troupes en
revue
depuis lundi les 4290 militaire qui
descendront à pied la plus belle avenue
du monde répète cet exercice quatre fois
par jour
malgré cette préparation très minutieuse
le sentiment de fierté l'emportent le
capitaine amélie originaire des yvelines
défilera dimanche avec ses hommes avant
de rejoindre dans quelques jours
l'institut des hautes études de défense
nationale véritable honneur de pouvoir
défiler à la tête donc de certains de
mes personnels on pourrait dire donc de
mon unité pour terminer un petit peu
comme on dirait avec panache
7 ce temps de commandement
pour certains ce défilé 2018 sera une
première et prendra même des airs de
réunion de famille un père et son fils
tous deux affectés à la base aérienne
116 de vélizy-villacoublay défileront
ensemble le 14 juillet tu vois une
fierté de représenter son pays et puis
se sont armés et messi rang content
d'être là moi c'est la deuxième fois sur
le champs elysées c'est vraiment un
plaisir de défiler avec mon fils qui
pensent que l'information qu'il a pu
suivre sur la base d' apporter le
maximum d'informations je pense qu'ils
soutiennent des défis liés au thème du
défilé cette année fraternité d'armes
sous l'uniforme l'engagement d'une vie
un engagement visible le 14 juillet sur
les champs elysées c'est la fin de ce
set 8 l'hebdo saison 2017-2018 merci de
nous avoir suivis un grand merci à
l'ensemble de l'équipe tv 78 je pense
notamment aux monteurs à l'infographiste
à l'administration ou encore bien sûr à
la rédaction
sans eux le résumé de l'actualité ne
serait pas possible passer un bel été et
d'excellentes vacances sur tv 78
[Musique]